[Música]
con el 50,90% de los votos Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva del partido de los
trabajadores es el nuevo presidente
electo de Brasil el actual presidente
Jair bolsonaro derrotado en esta
contienda electoral no ha dado
declaraciones frente a los resultados
los mandatarios de diferentes países han
felicitado a Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
por su triunfo en las urnas coincidieron
en destacar el proceso democrático que
ha tenido Brasil y también en su
intención de querer trabajar con Lula en
la unidad de la región
y estas elecciones tuvieron lugar en un
ambiente fuertemente polarizado el
presidente electo enfrentará importantes
retos económicos sociales
medioambientales y también de coyuntura
internacional pero es tal vez la unidad
de los brasileños el reto más importante
a nivel nacional
Hola Bienvenidos a este espacio de
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González hoy la noticia destacada está
en Brasil este país ya tiene nuevo
presidente se trata de Luis Ignacio Lola
da Silva Quien ganó el escrutinio con el
50,9% frente al actual mandatario Yair
bolsonaro quien obtuvo el 49,1% de los
votos Lula regresa al poder en un país
dividido con un discurso lleno de
promesas en materia económica social y
también de medio ambiente escuchemos
el mundo el extraña a Brasil
extrañan aquel Brasil soberano que
hablaba de igual para igual con los
países más ricos y poderosos y que al
mismo tiempo contribuía y aportaba con
el desarrollo de los países más pobres
Brasil que apoyó el desarrollo de los
países africanos por medio de
cooperación inversión y transferencia de
tecnología que trabajó por la
integración de América Latina de América
del Sur del Caribe que fortaleció
mercosur y ayudó a crear el g20 una azul
hoy en día nosotros estamos diciéndole
al mundo que Brasil regresó que Brasil
Es demasiado grande para ser relegado a
este triste papel de aislado en el mundo
las calles de diferentes ciudades
brasileñas han sido el escenario de las
manifestaciones de Los Seguidores de
Lula quienes celebraron su triunfo y
también su regreso al poder para un
tercer mandato el ahora presidente
electo esperó los resultados en la
ciudad de San Pablo en compañía de
Seguidores y de sus colaboradores de
campaña justamente la emblemática
avenida paulista en el centro de Sao
Paulo fue el punto de concentración de
miles de Seguidores de Lula que
festejaron su triunfo allí
significa Esperanza la esperanza de vida
mejores la esperanza de que volveremos a
ser felices porque nos conocemos
es la vida es el dolor y es la victoria
de terminación mucha determinación y
sobre todo justicia él es la justicia
tengo miedo de que Lula no asuma el
cargo sí habrá un golpe de estado No lo
sé pero le apoyamos luchamos hasta el
final
de acuerdo con el tribunal supremo
electoral de Brasil las elecciones
transcurrieron en un ambiente de total
calma con incidentes mínimos lo que
desvirtúa los señalamientos del
presidente Jair bolsonaro que criticaba
el proceso del voto electrónico con este
proceso democrático también se pone en
fin a cuatro años de gobierno de la
derecha en Brasil desde Río de Janeiro
nuestra corresponsal Valeria saccone
tiene más detalles de la jornada
hoy Brasil ha elegido a su presidente es
Luis Ignacio luna que después de 12 años
vuelve al poder el 1 de enero empezará
su tercer mandato ha sido una victoria
difícil un resultado apretado una
victoria amarga que supone una serie de
cosas primero el voluntarismo ha salido
reforzado de esas elecciones además la
gobernabilidad va a ser muy difícil
porque el 2 de octubre las elecciones
legislativas tanto la cámara de los
diputados como el senado tuvieron una
mayoría bolsonarista en un país tan
polarizado Lula va a tener que hacer un
esfuerzo muy grande para conquistar el
voto de la oposición a hacer muchas
negociaciones en un país recordamos que
mi presidencialista esto quiere decir
que el congreso tiene un papel
fundamental y eso lo vimos en 2016 con
el impeachment de edilma roussef que fue
del poder precisamente por una decisión
de los congresistas además nula ahora
por fin va a tener que desvelar qué va a
ser con a la economía en su campaña él
se ha limitado a repetir lemas bastante
ingenuos Y genéricos como vamos a ser
felices de nuevo o vamos a comer picaña
ahora va a tener que decir que va a ser
para contener la inflación el precio de
la gasolina y sobre todo cómo piensa con
tener los ambiciosos planos sociales que
quieren implementar Luna durante la
campaña pidió un cheque en blanco a los
electores basado en todo lo que hizo en
sus dos mandatos de gobierno llega ahora
el momento de la verdad para demostrar
lo que sabe y lo que puede hacer y
diferentes líderes de América y
referentes europeos reconocieron
rápidamente El Triunfo de Luis Ignacio
Lola da Silva con como nuevo presidente
de Brasil despejando así cualquier
posibilidad de que los resultados sean
denunciados o por parte derechistas Yair
bolsonaro en sus mensajes los
mandatarios remarcaron la voluntad de
afianzar lazos con el gigante
suramericano
a los pocos minutos de ser declarado
vencedor de las elecciones los demás
líderes del mundo reconocieron
rápidamente al nuevo mandatario un gesto
que desterró las posibilidades de
desconocer los resultados por parte del
bando de Jair bolsonaro la izquierda
latinoamericana celebró al instante El
Triunfo de Lula el presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro fue el primero en
pronunciarse con un breve tuit el
chileno Gabriel borich también se
manifestó con un mensaje escueto el
mandatario de Cuba Miguel Díaz canel
Bermúdez fue más prolijo Cuba te
felicita querido compañero atrasaron tu
Victoria con métodos atroces pero no
pudieron impedir que vencieras con el
voto del pueblo regresa Lula regresa el
partido de los trabajadores regresa a la
justicia social en Estados Unidos la
Casa Blanca Se comprometió a fortalecer
los lazos con el gigante sudamericano
envío mis felicitaciones a Luis Ignacio
y Lula da Silva por su elección como
próximo presidente de Brasil tras unas
elecciones libres justas y creíbles
espero que trabajemos juntos para
continuar la cooperación entre los dos
países en los próximos meses y años
desde Europa la tardía ahora no impidió
el envío de congratulaciones hacia Lula
juntos uniremos nuestras fuerzas para
hacer frente a los numerosos retos
comunes y renovar el vínculo de amistad
entre nuestros dos países desde Portugal
el Primer Ministro Antonio Costa hizo
honor al vínculo directo que une a
Brasil con la Unión Europea
yo he tenido la oportunidad de felicitar
calurosamente a Lula por su elección
como presidente de la república de
Brasil Espero que trabajemos juntos en
los próximos años En beneficio de
Portugal y Brasil pero también en torno
a las grandes causas globales
una nueva era en Brasil Inicia con el
retorno del hule al poder y al parecer
según la red social Twitter para la
mayor satisfacción de todos Ahora la
pregunta que queda es que la espera al
nuevo mandatario Pues Lula tendrá que
asumir importantes retos en temas
económicos y sociales después de la
pandemia del Coby 19 así como en materia
medioambiental y geopolítica debido a la
coyuntura internacional pero es tal vez
la unidad de los brasileños el mayor
reto que tiene Lula en política interna
el país que ASUME Luis Ignacio olurada
Silva Brasil eligió a su mandatario de
los próximos cuatro años en medio de la
polarización que dejan estas elecciones
el nuevo presidente tendrá que tomar
decisiones contundentes para combatir
temas como el hombre según datos
oficiales 33 millones de hogares pasan
hambre en el país sudamericano es decir
el 15% de su población Y aunque las
Naciones Unidas lo sacó del mapa del
hombre en 2014 la cifra a retrocedido
durante las últimas dos décadas en
septiembre la tasa de desempleo en
Brasil disminuyó por séptimo mes
consecutivo hasta el nivel más bajo
desde 2015 sin embargo la agencia
Nacional de estadísticas informó que
alrededor de 9.5 millones de brasileños
se encuentra sin trabajo actualmente
Brasil todavía sufre las consecuencias
económicas de la pandemia Y aunque se
espera que el producto interno bruto
para 2022 sea del 2.7% siendo superior a
la de Estados Unidos este no representa
un crecimiento exponencial el medio
ambiente es uno de los temas cruciales
durante la administración de bolsonaroz
se le acusó de no proteger activistas
indígenas y de desarrollar políticas a
favor de las Industrias según el
Instituto Nacional de pesquisas
especiales más de 47.000 kilómetros
cuadrados de zonas verdes fueron
deforestadas durante dicha
administración en cuanto al liderazgo
geopolítico Brasil ocupó El séptimo
puesto de Las mayores economías del
mundo entre 2010 y 2014 en comparación a
los últimos años posicionándose en la
casilla número 12 de igual manera se
esperaba que el país sudamericano
asumiera al liderazgo del bloque
económico de los briggs sin embargo las
estrategias no han sido suficientes para
lograr su objetivo
es todo en las noticias gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]